en italie à présent le mouvement 5
étoiles semble au bord de la rupture le
parti anti système qui fait partie du
gouvernement depuis trois ans pourrait
bien éclater et on va voir tout cela
avec fabrizio tribu duo bugatti
journalistes de la rédaction web de rt
france tout de suite
rt sur le web
[Musique]
bonjour fabrizzio alors le parti de
beppe grillo aujourd'hui au pouvoir est
traversée par une crise politique
on le disait la situation est-elle si
tendue finalement bonjour olivier alors
en effet ces derniers jours ont été
marqués par des échanges plutôt virulent
3 2 ep commenté péter grillo qui
représente aujourd'hui une espèce de
figure bus est bicéphale à la tête du
mouvement 5 étoiles en fait alors que
giuseppe compter dit refuser de jouer un
simple rôle de figuration beppe grillo
au contraire l'accusent pas connaître
l'identité réelle dû mouvement qui en
alors en fait ce sont eux revenus mais
au moins au point que la presse
italienne a rapporté un échange très vif
entre eux lors duquel je les paie compte
et aurait relancé avec les griots qu'il
ne les y reprendrait plus autrement que
par conférences de presse interposées
alors faut-il y voir une querelle d'ego
ou une véritable fracture idéologique
en réalité c'est l'identité du mouvement
5 étoiles lui-même qui est en jeu lors
de cette lors de ces débats en soit son
idéologie a bien évolué depuis sa
fondation d'abord aux sceptiques en fait
il a désormais abandonné l'idée d'un
référendum sur la sortie de l'euro et
l'union européenne est conforme son
programme économique aux critères de
maastricht
quand outre la volonté d'ailleurs de
mettre deux épées compter sous tutelle
et où beppe grillo sous tutelle sur
l'enfance aux classes de l'un ou l'autre
des points de vue nous était conté
aimerait surtout structurer le mouvement
en fait en véritable parti politique qui
est un parti qui sont partis modérés un
parti de gouvernement avec des règles
bien établies et des instances aussi
qu'ils soient bien établies
beppe grillo quant à lui que désire
al'inverse conserver son rôle de garant
qui est jusque là c'est nébuleux et
surtout la forme actuelle de son
mouvement qui est bien plus fluide et
sans doute aussi beaucoup plus fidèle à
l'esprit originel du mouvement 5 étoiles
alors ces divergences sont telles
consignes ici via blue finiront-elles
part convoqué une scission du mouvement
selon vous alors pour le moment tout
semble suspendu en fait à la décision de
deux épées compter qu'ils y laissent
planer le doute sur sa volonté de faire
cavalier seul
en réalité il est poussée par son
entourage et plusieurs ministres aussi a
fondé son propre parti
le problème c'est que pour l'instant
aucune décision semble être prises et il
est clair que si tu étais content et
venait
à prendre la décision de fonder un pur
parties afin de donner vie à ses
propositions comme il souhaite le faire
et comme il a plusieurs fois annoncé ce
serait non sans conséquences sur le
paysage politique italien
merci beaucoup fabrizzio muzio billets à
tirer pour aller plus loin on peut vous
lire sur notre site
rt france points à tv